No matter where you get your textures for use inside
of Unreal Engine 5, whether it's something
you've created yourself or something
you've downloaded from online or purchased
from one of the many online asset stores,
you need to make sure that texture adheres to a few
rules.
The first rule is that no matter
what dimension that texture is in the x or the y-axis,
that dimension needs to be a power of 2.
That means that the x-axis or the y-axis
needs to be something like 2, 4, 8, 16, 32, 64, 128, 256, 512,
1024, 2048, 4096, and 8192.
Anything from one of those numbers in the x or the y-axis
will give you a texture that will
work with Unreal's built-in texture streaming systems,
as well as make sure that that texture packs more
efficiently into memory.
When you import a texture into Unreal,
it's going to tell you a number of different things.
For example, it'll first tell you the imported size,
as well as the streaming method, the size it takes on disk,
and the number of mipmaps.
Now, mipmap might be a new term to many people.
And mipmap is something that Unreal
does behind the scenes if your texture meets
this power of 2 requirement.
Mipmaps are level of details for your texture,
and they're a way to help reduce your texture's cost when
it's viewed in a distance very far away from the camera.
We'll cover mipmapping in the next few slides.
But it's important to understand
that in order to have this advantage
and have Unreal do this work for you,
your texture needs to maintain that power of 2 ratio.
Let's take a look at the next texture.
This next texture, again, imported at 1024 by 1024.
Note a method, virtual stream.
That's right, if we're dealing with virtual textures,
no matter if those are streaming virtual textures
or runtime virtual textures,
we need to ensure that the data we're feeding into there
meets this power of 2 requirement.
As you can see, we still have a very small resource size
because we're using virtual textures
and very important number of mips, 11.
The last version of this texture,
imported at 1,000 by 1,000, method not streamed.
Resource size, 512, number of mips, 1.
This is very bad.
This means that this particular texture,
no matter where we use it
or no matter how far away it is from the camera,
will always be used at full resolution.
And this is gonna create a number of different problems,
both visually and for performance.
Now, in order to check any of your texture settings,
we can open up Unreal.
And by double clicking on a texture, like so,
we'll open it up inside of the texture editor.
And in the details at the top is where all of the settings
for this texture should be located.